In every single one of us there is a void
that can never be filled.
A part of us that yearns for a complete and
definitive understanding of the life that
engulfs us.
An omniscient end point in the pursuit of
knowledge.
At any moment, a new scientific discovery
or technological advancement could occur and
cause our current conception of reality to
crumble.
And after that, it will just as likely happen
again and again into eternity.
Every answer comes with a new question.
Every step forward illuminates more of a trail
with no destination in sight.
We posses a level of intelligence that seemingly
never meets the needs of the reality that
precedes it.
We are conscious enough to perceive the world
and add two and twos together.
We are conscious enough to ask questions based
on our perceptions and logical summations.
But we are not conscious enough to create
and sustain conclusive overarching answers
from it all.
Our most meaningful questions can only be
speculated.
Questions like where we come from.
Why we are here.
Where we are going.
And what is the point of it all?
The simple fact is, we currently have no way
of finding answers to these questions.
Perhaps these answers do not even exist in
conclusive form.
Or perhaps humans are not built with the purpose
to ever find them.
When reflecting on our inability to conclusively
answer our most basic existential questions
over the last several hundred thousand years
of human existence, it begins to feel hopeless.
And it is our continuing ignorance of reality
that creates the void that we can never quite
fill.
It is why we chase habitual distractions and
temporary pleasures in life.
Because what is the point of living without
answers as to why we live at all?
And furthermore, what is the point of living
without any real prospect for these answers?
But arguably, not having all of the answers
is the biggest reason to live.
As humans, we operate from a system of duality
that cares about logic and understanding as
well as emotion and feeling.
Our purpose and enjoyment of life is not bound
exclusively to a finite endpoint of the pursuit
of knowledge.
An endpoint to our questionings and revelations
about reality would be an end to our humanity.
It is the perpetual game of cat and mouse
that we play with reality that stimulates
vigor in life.
Without it, what would there be to strive
for?
What would there be to feel emotion over?
The part of human life that is so profoundly
interesting would cease without it.
We should not live with existential angst
and a constant chip on our shoulder because
we do not and cannot possess definitive answers
to all of our questions.
Instead, we should live with the excitement
and wonder that comes from the fact that because
of this, we will always possess the potential
for new discoveries and new worlds of life.
We will always be able to create theories
and meaning and experience the awe of their
realizations.
It is deeply human to strive for answers and
to move towards new understandings and explanations.
To fantasize about the singularity between
humanity and the reality in which it resides.
To visualize an end point of intelligence
and become synchronized with absolute truth.
But it is also deeply human to never achieve
this.
And to believe and depend on this occurring
misses the entire point.
The pursuit of understanding and knowledge
can and should exist for itself.
This pursuit is what makes us who we are.
Excitement, wonder, and humanity itself are
all rooted in the very fact that life, or
at least our understanding of it, is constantly
in flux.
New possibilities arise with every second
that passes and we must enjoy playing the
game that this creates, simply for the sake
of playing the game.
If we view life in this way, the void we all
have within us will begin to feel a little
less deep.